welcome back the media is just getting
more and more ridiculous with their
anti-trump hatred listen to this one
MSNBC host drop all pretense of
objectivity and actually give joe biden
advice on how to counter the president
during this crisis do they need to do it
in a bigger way you could what did you
just call it the president's daily clown
show that's his press briefing should
joe biden be counter-programming that
should he be creating his own shadow
government shadow cabinet shadow swat
team and getting up there at a podium
every night saying here's the crisis
we're in here's what we need to do to
address this and here is sleepy joe's
latest attack on trump's leadership
these are people who are frightened and
they're looking for leadership and what
bothers me what bothers me so much is
the president united states doesn't take
responsibility the president of united
states acts like this is not nothing is
his fault
nothing is his responsibility Tara Dana
I'm not really sure who that was on
MSNBC I don't think she was a primetime
host cuz I've never seen her in
primetime before so she shouldn't really
be giving that much of an opinion
I guess she's during the day or
something that seemed a little out of
bounds in my opinion what are you
[Laughter]
regardless of I know our she's on it's
such a bad idea it is such a bad idea
terrible I mean we've just spent a week
and a half talking about how there's
confusion about whether the federal
government or the governors are going to
reopen the economy and now we all agree
okay so there's collaboration and the
governor's help make decisions based on
some guidelines to get from the federal
government look I understand that Joe
Biden is in a bind that's bad but what
she is suggesting one it is a terrible
idea if you are a patriotic American
because you cannot have two presidents
at the same time you have one president
at a time and I'm sorry they're in this
predicament where they had to try to
campaign during a pandemic but that's
the situation they're in this idea is
like what I used to do
with my sister when I got home from
school after I had an after-school snack
I would make her play school with me and
this is like playing government you
don't do this for it's like make-believe
and I think would just make a terrible
terrible sledding for Joe Biden yeah
well you played school and and gutfeld
probably played doctor what do you think
Greg I think I saw that joke coming like
a frisbee in the desert ten miles away
all right what I find interesting is
that Joe literally is in the shadows
that's what's so funny about her
commentary yeah but but here's the thing
nobody Joe Nancy Chuck
Liz AOC nobody can answer the question
what would you do differently than
Donald Trump what would you do when when
would you start the economy how would
you do it they can't they can't say it
because they know they have a 50% chance
of being wrong so they're petrified of
actually raising their hand and going oh
I have an idea let's do it now the kid
so instead they're not going to step
forward what they're gonna do is you're
gonna wait for President Trump to flip
the switch or the dimmer and any
collateral damage that there is then
they will leap forward and there we go
ha we wouldn't have done that no siree
we wouldn't have done that you did that
too late or you didn't do enough or you
did too much or you're an autocrat or
you didn't take control but they will
not tell you when they're gonna start
they're not gonna tell you how they're
gonna start because they're too scared
of being wrong you're right because I
think Biden's stuck his neck out early
on the travel ban and he was dead wrong
one grade Joe Biden's I guess
performance in this quarantined campaign
would you give him an a a B or C and
then why would you give him that grade
well I think that in Biden's case it's a
matter of getting out in public and not
allowing the virus which has changed the
campaign landscape definitely for
everybody on either side here and not
allowing himself to be pushed out of any
spotlight because he's not campaigning
so what you get is he's now on TV more
than ever and of course he's doing those
live streams from his basement in
Delaware somewhere so he's on a lot of
TV and he and he has also as I mentioned
these streaming efforts that are going
out so I think it's gotten much better
it comes up a great I'd say initially
not so good and now pretty good but you
know he's up against President Trump who
has this daily press briefing that's a
you know as the president likes to say
on par with the bachelors finale and
Monday Night Football I do think that
you know an answer this question though
you've got I think everyone I've met
who's run for president thinks they're
about to win and so if you're going to
win in this environment you better have
a plan and I don't think there's any
reason that he shouldn't be saying to
the American people here's how I would
be dealing with it and I think that he's
been pretty clear and I think others
have said so as well we need to do a
better job when it comes to testing in
this country providing supplies to our
medical workers making sure that you
know the bank computers don't get all
screwed up when we try to deliver
stimulus checks to our workers these are
legitimate criticisms of this
administration and he's got to be able
to say I would do a better job mm-hmm
yeah Katie maybe he could ask Liz war
and have a little help with the plan she
now wants to be as VP that is true but
do we really think that Joe Biden is
capable of running a shadow government
he can hardly run his own interviews
when he's kidding he can hardly figure
out what day it is at this point there's
no way he could start running a shadow
government and I'm sure that the
Communist Party of China would love for
Joe Biden to start doing something like
that considering he's been lacks on
China he's in sympathetic to them his
son has ties to business ties to China
which questionably may still be there I
mean the he was against the travel ban
and allowing you know people going in
and out of the country while the virus
was spreading around the world
I mean I'm sure they would love for him
to continue the work of the World Health
Organization and covering for China on
this issue and he still needs to learn
how to coffin to his elbow we're gonna
give him a little exactly coming up